hey everybody and welcome to what i
kind of consider to be season two of the
park campaign let's play
today we're starting with the 10
scenarios in the taste of adventure dlc
which all of which are made by me
although i did not set the goals
and i know sebastian and garrett have
changed up a few things here and there
so
don't trust me to be an expert in these
scenarios but still
i think it's fun to try these and see
how i do
a few things i want to mention before i
start building on the 8th of december
an update is coming to parchitect which
i'm super hyped about
and i know i can't say this completely
unbiasedly because i've been here with
the development of parking for so long
but an update is dropping where
multiplayer
becomes part of the game which is kind
of unreal to consider
because the game basically had to be
written again from the ground up as much
as i understand it
but it allows you to play with up to
eight people on the same map
and build simultaneously in real time so
that's gonna be super exciting i'm
already thinking of what i can do
to make some special videos about that
and
it's just gonna be a really great time
also of course i'm playing with dlcs now
not just taste of adventure but
also the booms and blooms dlc which i
announced in an earlier video but i
haven't used any pieces of yet
um so before i start building i'm just
gonna show off really quickly why the
game is gonna start looking quite a bit
differently
from what you're probably used to if
you're just watching
my old scenario play throughs anyway
let's just not mince too many words
about it and
get right into today's scenario which is
yukatan ridge
you've somehow managed to purchase some
historical mayan temple grounds
to construct a crowd-pleasing theme park
the local government remains adamant
that the temple ruins may not be
destroyed or terraformed in any way
but they didn't say wait i have to click
the rocket but they didn't say anything
about building rides all over them
um so first of all i did come up with
this scenario and
um i'm very sorry to anybody who lives
in this region of mexico i know it's
actually still
very much uh mayan identity is still
very much alive
and the the idea of building a theme
park on
heritage ground is is well obviously
very unethical that said i think it's a
it's a fun setting for
a scenario in this game and i did write
this text with a little bit of irony
intended
um but mostly it's gonna be an
interesting gameplay thing because it
means that we won't be able to delete
anything and we also won't be able to
make use of terraforming
so that's kind of a limitation and
challenge on behalf of this scenario
now the goals are to have an operating
profit of at least
to have an operating profit of at least
two thousand dollars
and then some optional goals as well
which aren't too difficult so let's just
get into it
and i'll quickly show you what's
different now and then we can start
building
so here's the park uh pretty small and
as you can tell we're really gonna have
to try
and work around the limitations of not
being able to delete any scenery
and do anything with the terraforming
that said
we do have quite a few rides to work
with and even some good decent roller
coasters
so that should be pretty good and also
in the scenery tab and i think this is
where the biggest changes come in
because i wasn't playing with dlcs on in
my base game
uh playthrough of the campaign i have
lots of new stuff now which are part of
not just the taste of adventure dlc but
also the booms and blooms dlc which i
purchased a while ago
but just never used anything from and
for booms and blooms i think the
most spectacular changes are in the
foliage which is the blooms part of the
name
you can tell all of the new trees and
shrubs by the fact that they have this
little firework-ish
flowery background and these trees
especially look quite a bit different
from what you're used to in the base
game they're a bit more detailed
larger some of them are too and
especially if you recolor them you can
get
uh completely different foliage
landscapes now than what we're used to
um i quite like this palm tree it's
gonna be nice for tropical maps
um but also there's this really good oak
tree which is
huge compared to everything that's been
in the game so far
which i'll surely make a lot of use of
and then there's just all kinds of other
trees which i'm gonna get
used to at some point hopefully and know
how to work them into my parks
all that just to say you're gonna see a
lot more variety in the foliage
which is really cool and then another
thing to keep in mind is that i now have
new scenery which comes with the
adventure dlc
of course we have the adventure scenery
pack as well
which comes with a little bit of foliage
as you can see some tropical-ish foliage
but mostly building structures all of
this stuff which
this scenario is made with as well so
that's pretty neat i really like some of
the textures that these pieces come with
but also it comes with the candy lens
theme which is not part of this scenario
but which i might
start using in some later scenarios as
well
so all that to say the game is gonna
look a little bit different from this
point onward
anyway um i think i've said what i
wanted to say
let's just start a time lapse and see
what i can make of it
all right so right off the bat i figured
we need a money-making machine so i
started building a coaster before i did
literally anything else because we need
to fit in something that will help us
toward the goal of making
two thousand dollars a month which is
pretty hefty
and i figured the best thing for the uh
for the job was probably going to be the
stand-up coaster i think that's the
standout right here
the other option was building a hyper
coaster which is way out of my budget
right now and there was also the mine
train but it's just
gonna be too small and not quite gonna
carry the stats
besides i think the stand-up ghost is
actually one of the most
fun coasters to build in this game which
is kind of ironic considering that in
real life
they're very unpopular in the coaster
enthusiast community
but then again if i'm allowed to go on a
small off-topic tangent i think a lot of
that is due to the fact that
americans are kind of over represented
in the international coaster community
and togo of america which is a different
subsidiary of the same company of the
original
japanese company there must have been
something with their manufacturing
because
their american togos were very well
and widely known to be horrible
but the general consensus seems to be
that togo coasters in japan were better
i can't speak for much of it because
i've never been on a togo in america but
i have been
on a togo well a bunch of togos in japan
and honestly from my experience they
were pretty good
and the one togo stand-up coaster that
i've been on
i've kind of enjoyed more than the b m
stand-up coaster i've been on which
i know is probably going to lend me in
hot water with many coaster enthusiasts
to think i'm an
absolute idiot but honestly the vertical
loops on a togo stand up or
at least a good smooth togo stand up
they really hit different
they're pretty fun and it doesn't
overstay its welcome whereas with a b m
stand up you still have to spend five
more minutes meandering through a boring
layout
while your balls are getting crunched um
but anyway that's way beside the point
i just figured that in this scenario
right here the togo stand-up coaster is
the best way to go
so i built that thing uh keeping in mind
also because space is super limited
that i had to leave certain areas blank
so i can
play some flat rides on it in a later
stage
one of those places is right here next
to the loop but then also within the
helix i
made sure that the space between the
helix and the corkscrew is just large
enough for a twister
so at some point in the scenario i'm
gonna place a twister over there
and then of course we also have that
sort of lower
uh yeah really the lowest point of the
park on the right in the screen here
which is a perfect place for a big flat
ride to go as well so i wanted to keep
all those spaces
empty so in a way this coaster seems
like it's way too spread out and way too
big
but with its layout i'm trying to keep
in mind where else i want to place
things at a later stage
and really this this coaster doesn't
have too much of a footprint if you look
at it that way
i decided to keep the space between the
lift hill and the loop empty for
a big food court building and then of
course
the area in front of the station can
also be a another path
area leading to different parts of the
park so all things together i think this
is a layout that is
realistic enough for a toco stand-up
coaster because they are quite simple
and straight to the point
they're coasters from the 80s after all
so just a loop and a corkscrew and some
elements between it
should usually do the job maybe two
loops and two corkscrews whatever you
want to go for but
that's the basic premise and everything
else is just
trying to make it work within the
confines of this scenario
now some other things that are of course
fun to point out i
just built a small temple decoration
piece
next to the flat ride because these rip
tides are
really huge and they come up really high
when they start spinning so it's not
quite as easy to build a building around
the flat ride so i figured it would be
nice to at least add some scenery next
to it
and then there's also lots of foliage
some of which is new
if you're paying attention you can see
that the trees are from the booms and
blooms dlc and then also of course the
temple pieces that i was using
are from the adventure dlc so at this
point
forward really keep in mind that most of
the stuff i'm building
will still be from the base game but
there will also be a lot of stuff that
you don't have
if you have just the base game um just
so that anybody who's watching this and
is thinking of buying parkitect
knows that you still have to buy the dlc
too if you want to see
everything that's on screen right now on
the other hand people that are
interested in the dlc or maybe already
have it but haven't messed around with
it much
um i guess you guys can see you know
what's exactly in it and what you can do
with some of the scenery pieces
for me to some extent it's also
trying to figure out how these pieces
work again uh because i made the
scenarios
for the adventure pack i think well over
a year ago already so at the time i
really looked at the pieces
and tried to incorporate them as much as
possible and see what you can do with it
i really had a sort of
exploration stage at that that point in
time
but in the past year i've only been
making vanilla campaign videos so i
haven't used all of these pieces in a
while so for me it's kind of
yeah a re-exploration of what you can do
with these things again
they're really fun pieces though and
there are some new great textures in it
and especially because the base game has
many pieces that don't have a texture
the fact that these adventure pieces all
come with different textures
just opens up so many new possibilities
and makes the game look a little bit
different
so i think that's cool for this building
i was just inspired for
or by the entrance building there's not
really a very specific
style to it i guess and honestly it
might not even be that accurate
i'm just looking at general mexican
urban architecture not even specifically
you know traditional old temple
buildings
but just building something vaguely of
the modern era
of that region in the world so it's not
super themed but my idea for this park
was that it is you know an old temple
grounds area so you have to make a clear
distinction between the buildings that
are
really old temples or inspired by old
temples are trying to imitate that look
and then the buildings that are not from
that era at all and not just from the
modern era and are just a mishmash of
maybe some native motifs but also
colonial architecture
and general international architecture
so
it's uh it's quite a hodgepodge at this
point over here but i think it
kind of works in the adventure theme
anyway so i'm pretty happy with it
so yeah moving on here we have the
lowest point of the park where as i
said i would place a flat ride i figured
at the end of the day
the best flat right for this place is
probably the airplanes
i think it kind of works in the theme as
well i mean
you do see airplanes in the mountains in
in santa may i mean
where do you not see them but i don't
know they just fit into an adventure
theme for me for some reason maybe it's
the fact that
from my perspective which is some dude
from europe
uh adventure theme will always be
connected to
airplanes because it's the way that you
go to another part of the world
but now that i think about i think this
connotation is very dependent on where
you're from
i imagine if you're actually from south
america you might not have that
sort of connection at all but for me
anyway and
i guess for many of my european pals
tropical
themes will always go with airplanes
because we go to the tropics with
airplanes
it's kind of stupid but then again i
think your own
national biases and stuff always come
into play when it comes to how you
perceive
themes in theme parks honestly that
that's that's a whole phd theme probably
but
anyway for me i figured this ride could
fit here it also perfectly fit the
footprint so
i i thought it was the best thing to put
here and then
uh down below there i have a small
ferris wheel
which is kind of unusual i guess to put
the ferris wheel at the
lowest point of your park usually it's
something you want to put on a hill
i think uh japan has many theme parks
that have really cool ferris wheels
placed on top of hills
i know china has done this quite a few
times as well
looks really cool i'm a big fan uh but
in this case i just needed a flat ride
that fit
in this space here and the double ferris
wheel was the best way to go
i do think given the fact that the whole
park is
located on top of the hills because
realistically these kinds of
uh temple complexes were usually on
geographic high points
it doesn't matter that the ferris wheel
is in the lowest part of the park
because it can still overlook a valley
uh to the bottom and it's still one of
the highest peaks
in the general area probably uh
but it is curious a ferris wheel is
usually the kind of right that i would
tell people you know put that on the on
a high point in your park or
somewhere and and an axis where
different symmetrical lines come
together so you have
really cool views from the ferris wheel
and this this case is completely
different
then again it is a double ferris wheel i
guess so that's a slightly different
story again
but yeah i just figured it was the best
place for this flat ride in this park
and then when it comes to all of the
other scenery by the way i am making a
lot of use of the new palm trees which
i'm a really big fan of
some of the other changes that are kind
of minor
but really make a huge difference is
that you can now recolor
basically every foliage piece and also
resize most of the trees
so anything that's just too small or too
large for your liking or the colors just
a little bit off
you can now well basically recolor all
of it
we've always been able to recolor the
trees but the bushes were an exception
for a while and i'm still super happy
that
we can now recolor bushes i know it's
been a while and i'm not
new to this news at all but i do think
it makes a huge difference especially if
you go back to
some of my earliest park campaign
playthroughs and all of the foliage is
the same size and the same color
i think these small tweaks that you can
do for stuff uh makes
well all the difference it also makes
sure that you can place stuff within
certain hitboxes because i know for a
few of these palm trees i had to fit
them
next to buildings or next to rides and
resize them
just to be able to not have to put it
through
something else or to be able to place it
at all so
honestly the the whole resizing option
is really useful especially if you want
to make really dense foliage and want to
place stuff around right
now at this point i let the park run for
a while and if you look at the the
bottom left corner you can see that the
park is making profit
so that's really good i had to take a
loan
out at some point to pay for some of my
theming and
really while i'm building here i'm also
trying to slowly pay off that loan
just so that i don't pay as much for the
loan every month
[Music]
and also i'm just trying to save up some
money to see if i can build a new
coaster but that's somewhere in the far
future for now i decided to just focus
on
maintaining the park that i have so far
as well as i can because
one roller coaster and three flat rides
all of which
have decent excitement ratings that
should be enough
to go with uh i don't think i need to do
any big investments yet
for now i just wanted to make sure the
park keeps running correctly as it was
the first few months as i started
playing so i'm building a staff room
and a staff training room to make sure i
don't
run into some issues with vandalism or
dirty paths or things like that
and it also just works really well i
think in creating this kind of village
like atmosphere in the middle of the
valley and especially around the
entrance you sort of get a main street
idea
and then as it opens up into the rest of
the parks and you get to more of the
rides and the roller coasters
the the theming kind of changes to the
temple theming
which i think considering the setting
and the way that you come in
into this park i think that's the most
logical way to
to divide the park spatially at least
um so that's also why i'm putting all of
my facilities at the front here
i was considering for a while to put the
star facilities as a more
uh central location in the park which is
usually a bit better for uh gameplay
reasons because your staff doesn't have
to walk as much
but now sometimes i want to put the form
over function
and just do stuff for aesthetic reasons
instead
so i figured this was the best location
to do this
now you'll notice me here trying to get
rid of vandals because i had constant
attacks from vandalism
one of the best ways to get over that is
really
to build more rides and build more
intense rides because it's really just
when people are
well unhappy about the park or really
bored
that they start turning into vandals so
usually i like to prevent the problem
instead of fixing it when the vandals
come up but at this point i
wasn't ready yet to make another big
investment and i just wanted to focus on
finishing what i had so far so
sometimes you just have to make
everything invisible
and kick out the vandals and you just
have to do a little bit of manual labor
to find them and throw them out at least
they're very recognizable
uh they're also in corona times the only
people who actually follow the advice of
wearing face masks but
yeah whatever they're still a-holes
anyway um i finally decided to add a
theme
to this station and i'm very sorry to
anybody out there who's an expert of
south american temple architecture
um especially if the the region of
mexico
because this is this is probably very
inaccurate
but i just figured something like this
looks really cool honestly
this is very classical if i if i look at
it it's just
kind of classical architecture but with
south american motifs um
so maybe not the greatest station
building in that sense but i didn't want
to put too much thought in it and just
see what i could come up with in the
spot
one thing i do like about it though is
the subtle variations in colors
whether it would be the the border
around the building itself or the
different roof colors and stuff like
that
i think for too long in my park tech
playthroughs i've let everything be the
exact same color
and with the fact that you're completely
free to swap color palettes all the time
i think one of the greatest things you
can do in the game is just subtle
differences
in color everywhere which might not be
instantly noticeable but once you look
at the complete picture it does make a
small difference
anyway that's it for the stand-up
coaster
one more thing i wanted to do before i
took a step back
and looked at the park with you guys was
built my next big coaster
and well really the most intense one in
the park
and i figured what better coaster to
build than one of the new coasters from
the taste of adventure dlc and i say new
but taste of adventure is such an old
dlc at this point
i just haven't been able to build this
coaster type
in my scenario so far okay so i really
wanted to give it a try here
and it's the inverted spin spinning
coaster
which by the way for any coaster nerds
out there or non-coaster nerds
you can find the inverted spinning coast
in real life as well
there's one example of it called time
traveler at silver dollar city
but currently plopsaland in belgium
is also building another example of
these and it looks absolutely amazing
every sunday on their youtube channel
they're posting update videos of the
construction
and it looks really cool it's been one
of the most fun and exciting coaster
projects to follow this year in terms of
construction
so yeah lots of stuff happening in the
real world with this coaster type so i'm
really glad that it's been added in
parkitect even though it's already
been like a year or so it's a really fun
coaster to build
because you can add lift hills and
launches to it which is always great if
a coaster type is that flexible
and you can also make it go upside down
which is one of the craziest
experiences i can imagine i've never
been on a spinning coaster that also
inverts myself
for sure as soon as the one is open in
plop salons i'm going to try and make my
way out there someday
but right now i really can't speak for
the experience of how it feels to
spin in all of those different
directions i guess the
closest thing to it would be uh 4d
coasters like on agenika for instance
the cars flip vertically but at the same
time the track flips
horizontally and you get this crazy
spinning motion
in different directions like a gyroscope
that's something how i imagine riding
this kind of coaster would feel
so really fun coaster type in real life
and in the game
really fun to build as well because
they're really flexible
and in this case i decided it would
probably be best
to just have a kind of out and back
layout with a few inversions and
two launches uh to get the most out of
this coaster type
and also uh get the most out of my space
because space is incredibly limited in
this park of course
so all that i could really do with this
is try to hug the terrain
and stay close to the edges of the park
and see if i can leave enough space for
other rides as well and with that said
let's take a quick look and see how the
park is doing
well are you seeing what i'm seeing
because i'm seeing stunks right here
that's actually
i'm actually super pleasantly surprised
as to how much profit i made that month
wait wait a second what's that
uh okay i guess it's not gonna be quite
as much this month but
oh there's still four minutes left
enough to to
get very close to that 2000 probably i'm
honestly surprised i'm already this
close
i thought i would need at least two more
flat rides and a big roller coaster to
make it there but
maybe we already will sometime soon
anyway let's give a quick pov
of the stand-up coaster and the spinning
coaster because
that's what i'm really here for before i
move on
i really like this part where it's going
through the the buildings and you have
that interaction with the path and then
you fly over here past the flat ride
still actually need to fix those fences
and this is the future twister location
and uh just one corkscrew later we're
slamming into the brakes
it's funny how every single roller
coaster youtuber always says that
trains slam into brakes i don't know who
pointed this out
i found a comment about it recently and
i can't watch coaster youtube videos
anymore
without noticing it it's like one of
those verbs and
and nouns that is just so connected for
some reason
uh anyway let's do a quick pov of the
spinning coaster as well
to get that out of the way i added a
block break in front of the
lsm sections just to make sure that they
will also function as separate blocks
which is
quite important because if you don't do
that then a terrain is going to have to
wait until the next train has gone
through the entire circuit
before you can launch another train i
just hope that i can get the timings
right all the time that
the launches don't mess up and it
doesn't stop at the start of the launch
because with a rolling launch like this
you always have to make sure that even
if it's launching from a standstill
position
it can still make the track and here at
the end it's really spinning very well
kind of surprised actually at how well
it spins at some sections although not
every section of the track is as well
spun
but yeah altogether i'm pretty happy
with the layout
it also just looks pretty cool i think
it really has that sort of out and back
feel but at the same time it has this
very tangled mess of track near the
station
it's not too long but with two launches
i think it's a
it's a better experience than most
coasters in campaign maps or at least
most coasters in my own campaign maps
probably
um so yeah as far as the the layout
elements go
i guess we uh we have a dive loop and
then some
twists and turns two helixes into the
second launch uh
once again a dive loop and then a zero g
roll
over what in the future might be a very
fancy path
leading up to this temple uh still have
to figure that one out
i also have to say i say dive loop but i
forget dive looper a moment every single
time after all these years because
the direction the twist and the half
loop one of them
um but anyway we have a big temple
complex here where i also have something
planned it could be a flat ride but it
could also be a roller coaster station
i'm trying to weigh my options at this
point
but it's definitely going to be my next
big area of
expansion speaking of which i do have
a bunch of flat rides that i unlocked
through research
and i won't be able to build all of
these but some of them do symmetrically
fit like the jumper here
um i don't think the topple tower does
no it doesn't
it's kind of a shame i really love this
ride in game but
also in real life they're pretty fun not
gonna lie although they're also kind of
ball crunchers um and then of course
there's the the twister here but i also
got new roller coasters
among which an inverted coaster which i
think has some potential in this map
but it's going to be hard for me to
still build that because my only
decent space left is here
and i'm currently researching the junior
coaster and i'm actually thinking about
possibly building a junior coaster
instead we'll see what i end up doing
but i think it could work over here it's
probably going to be either a junior
coaster
or a mine train coaster and one or two
more flat rides and then
hopefully that'll be enough to reach the
goals of this scenario and if it isn't
i can always just launch some campaigns
and hopefully we'll make that 2000
in monthly profits anyway um so yeah
that's the plan without further ado
let's get back to building
so here we go by the way i just want to
mention a quick technical issue i know
my microphone is still crackling every
now and then
because i make these episodes in a kind
of well
chipping away manner where it sometimes
takes weeks to record one episode and i
just work on one bit at a time
i do hear them while i put them together
and edit them as well and i can just
hear
sometimes the crackling happens during
my voice recordings
especially during the live recordings
and i'm still not entirely sure why it
happens
so i really don't know how to fix it
either i don't know if it's my mic or my
computer
or the cable that my mic is plugged into
and it just happens every now and then
and it's not
you know a huge issue that
needs immediate solving it's just very
annoying
and i wish i knew what it was exactly
and i've talked about it many times in
videos
put it in in the text i never got too
many comments about it
but it's still something that i'm very
conscious about and
very annoyed with maybe one day the day
comes that i upgrade my mic and i don't
have to worry about this anymore
or i upgrade my computer either one of
the things
but um yeah if it's if it's annoying you
during this video
just to let you know that i'm aware of
it and i also notice it during editing
it's nothing too bad where i want to
re-record the whole thing
um but it's it's certainly a nuisance
anyway let's get back to topic
um because i'm building a station of
course i wasn't really too sure
what to do with these with this building
here um
but as you're probably noticing at this
point i
strategically placed all of the stations
of my roller coasters on locations where
you do have those temple pieces in the
game
i think that just works out best in
terms of terraforming
because you have these areas set up in
such a way that the
hills just go toward them and you get
these big rectangular plateaus
it just works for a coaster station and
originally i thought about these things
as
locations where you could put flat rides
and make them work
in a sort of symmetrical way together
with the terrain and scenery that's all
already there but i think it works very
well with
coaster stations as well and for one it
also helps you cover
up these spaces because i think it would
look kind of strange if you had
these uh big terraformed
rectangular spaces jutting out in the in
the map but then didn't do anything
specific with it
so i think they just work really well as
starting points not just for flat rides
but for roller coasters as well but then
obviously i do want to fit my stations
into the theme a bit
so this station as well is some sort of
temple building
although this one's a bit more of a
mixture as well because i also added
some
wooden sections with simple wooden posts
just to make sure that i could cover the
entire station and nobody is standing in
the rain in the queue
because the original temple building
just wasn't quite
large enough for the footprint and i
figured if i made the temple building
larger on this footprint
it just wouldn't really look realistic
anymore to what these aztec temples
typically looked like although once
again with a caveat that i'm far from an
expert when it comes to this theme
i just opened up some google images and
took some inspiration from
reference images of real life temples
and i'm using that as a sort of baseline
throughout this entire let's play but
there's
a lot of fantasy that's been added into
the mix
anyway that's the station for the
spinning coaster
now onto the twister which once again
i had a small challenge here because i
had to come up with a new roof structure
for this flat ride
i keep wanting to try and challenge
myself to come up with a new roof
structure for each of these
inevitably at some point i'm just going
to repeat structures that i've already
built and maybe forgotten about or
figure works perfectly in this specific
situation but for today
i still could come up with something new
and slightly different
to what i've done so far so what we have
here
is a sort of outer ring of metal
corrugated plates very similar to what
we have at the entrance
and then in the middle a big spiky spire
made with glass so that you can see
through it whenever i build these things
i do
like to make the flat right underneath
it visible even if just from a gameplay
perspective to make it clear that
there's a ride over there
you can instantly have a clear overview
of where the flat rides are and stuff
because of course in a real life setting
most flat rides with a roof over them
they don't have a glass roof but also in
a real-life setting you don't look at a
park from above
but you're just on ground level and i do
think the the difference in perspective
obviously
makes a huge difference in how you
approach theming in a theme park
or well a virtual theme park anyway
anyway moving on to the last coaster of
this episode and this is going to be
the final moneymaker and hopefully going
to be the what
wins me the scenario i think with this
coaster we should be comfortably able to
reach 2 000
of monthly revenue although we'll have
to see about that after this time lapse
of course
so i was uh just gonna go for the mine
train because i think it works best in
this situation
the only struggle is usually these
things stick very close to the terrain
and they are as terrain conforming as
possible
maybe even featuring a few tunnels or so
but
in this scenario i can't do anything
with the terrain i can't move it up or
down or
make any cutaways or the kind of stuff
that you usually really want to do with
my train coasters
so this one's just gonna have to be
raised a little bit above the ground
and i just have to put some effort into
making this thing
uh stick to the already existing terrain
and try to make it
mind train-ish that way so the way that
i decided to make this one work is of
course as always put the station
on that big temple spot at the top there
which has a very majestic path leading
up to it which
is kind of a cool thing but also kind of
a bad thing i imagine it looks
really cool and as a guest walking up
there it's it's it's probably one of the
coolest
weenies you could probably have in the
theme park but then again
it's a huge journey to walk up that hill
and usually you want your roller
coasters to just do that for you
by bringing you up with a lift hill the
only advantage of building the coaster
this way and putting the station
at almost the highest spot in the entire
layout because it is pretty unusual
is that you don't waste a lot of energy
the lift hill is kind of in the middle
of the layout you still have a few
curves before you go
into the lift hill so you don't waste
too much
potential energy going into the lift
hill don't need any breaks or anything
like that and then after the lift hill
you build up just
enough potential energy to make it back
to the station
through the whole layout that follows
and yeah
it's just perfect there's there's
something really satisfying about roller
coasters that
manage to be really fast throughout
their entire layout
and yet hit the brakes without slamming
into the brakes as theme park youtubers
like to say it and just
smoothly gliding into them and realizing
that you had just the right amount of
energy for your trip on the roller
coaster without making it too boring at
the end
it's it's just so satisfying and it's
something that can really only work out
with terrain coasters of course
but whenever it's possible i like to try
to make it possible because it's just
it's really nice um as for the layouts
of the mine train otherwise it's uh it
just does
some turns some slow hills and nothing
too
exciting the final elements kind of
reminds me
of what the ultimate at light water
valley does
it's very similar light water valley i
think is the only coaster
that does a full cloverleaf interchange
you know a highway interchange that's
like a clove relief
so if you want to take a left turn you
really have to take a right turn and you
do the whole like 270 degree turn
those things by the way are very
inefficient that cheap to build but
they're just horrible in terms of
traffic situations because different
streams of cars have to go through the
same road space
and it's much better to untangle them
with i don't know
a clover turbine interchange or just the
turbine interchange or stack
anyway getting massively off topic i
think the ultimate is the only
roller coaster with the clover
interchange element
it basically does that thing where it
does a few of those two 70 degree
helixes
uh in a row and then between that it
it goes over a bridge you might
recognize this from roller coaster
tycoon because it was in katie's world
as the storm um which is just one of
those classic roller coaster tycoon
scenarios as well
but yeah we basically get an element
very similar to that in this mine train
and i thought that was kind of
interesting
otherwise though let's be honest there's
not too much going on
and maybe this maybe this whole rant was
just
an excuse for me to talk about highway
interchanges because
god knows i haven't made a city skylines
video in
quite a while and when i don't do that
for a bit i guess i just start itching
to talk about urbanism again
it's been too long anyway for this
station
as always going for that aztec inspired
temple building
with with the funky roofs some of them
have very flat roofs but i've also found
some examples
of decorations on top of the roofs which
are usually quite blocky
so quite simple to achieve in the game
but a lot better than just a flat roof
and i think it works pretty well with
the theme
although of course i'm still slapping
lots of fantasy ideas on it as well so
lots of
painted decorations on the front and at
the same time also making it look a bit
ruined which i do realize is kind of
an anachronism in a sense because i'm
making these buildings look
as though they are the original temples
and not the
destroyed versions of the temples or the
kind of ruined versions of the temples
that we see nowadays
with all of the decorations still intact
but at the same time i'm putting so much
foliage on top of these and
throwing ferns and vines all over them
which is
kind of an either or scenario either
you're gonna make your temple ruined and
slap greenery on it or you make it
completely clean and still have the
details and the coloring on it and
i just wanted to go for both because it
looks cool and
let's just say it's it's still very much
a fantasy temple theme
at the end of the day but yeah that's uh
that's something i'm very aware of how
strange it is
it just the foliage just makes
everything look better so it's it's hard
to resist that stuff just slapping
foliage
in or around or on top of buildings that
you're not a huge fan of or even
buildings that you do like
just makes everything look better
usually like i guess there are a few
themes
where you do want buildings to be very
gritty and industrial where
this is an exception but usually foliage
just makes everything look better
which means that it really helps a lot
that we have new foliage in the game
by the way a final thing that i want to
build because i skipped forward here a
little bit as you can tell i
started to run the my train and also the
flat ride that i built in front of it
and quickly figured out that i easily
made enough money
to reach the goals of the scenarios
that's very nice
but also i realized that the zero the
zero g roll
in front of the the temple was floating
which is very
weird and i had to find a solution for
this that
simultaneously didn't come too close to
the hitboxes
of the spinning coaster which are pretty
big because it spins around and it's
also doing a flip
during the whole thing uh but also it's
crossing apart and also it's built half
over the launch section and also i
didn't want to block the view
of the temple as you're walking up the
path so
in the end i decided to build this crazy
weird lattice construction that upholds
the zero g
roll but at the same time leaves a lot
of space to
place its lag around all kinds of stuff
it's kind of like a real life twister
support but yeah i think it works out
pretty alright
and with that said we've basically
reached the end of our journey so let's
quickly hop into a real-time overview
and see what the puck looks like
all right so here we are almost making
that goal
thankfully i didn't have to redo
anything i didn't dip below the goal
that i had to reach
um unfortunately we didn't make it
before august year 2
instead we're in february year 6.
so yeah maybe that's not the greatest i
also didn't meet the optional goal
without using any track right blueprints
maybe that has something to do with
hmm yeah maybe that has something to do
with not reaching them before august
year 2.
whatever i made it i think that's all
that matters
and yeah it wasn't actually quite as
hard as i expected but then again
i think i was just putting my
expectations very high because i was
really afraid of building
a really nice map and then having to
throw it away because i didn't make it
oh by the way the launch is really fun
to see here as it
goes underneath the support structure
with the custom catwalks here and then
it
flips over this path i think there's
just really cool interaction here
clearly there are vandals in the park
because i literally just put a trash bin
here and it's already destroyed
anyway let's take a quick pov on the
coaster here i know i already missed the
first section that's kind of a shame but
let's just quickly follow it along here
so yeah not too much going on but we do
have a fun element
where it does the double to 70 degree
helix here
uh simple temple structure where there
was also an
unfinished temple structure nice
interaction actually between these two
coasters
that's pretty fun and yeah the first
element
is actually pretty fun on this coaster
too i think because it dips
out of the station with this well this
this pretty steep drop actually for a
mine train especially and then it
turns around kind of goes up but not too
much and then it again
falls pretty steeply underneath this
brake run so actually i think the most
fun part of this ride is actually what
you can
pretty much call a double down at the
start of the ride
jumping straight out of the station and
building up
a lot of momentum uh right there there
you go
that's i think a really fun maneuver and
it's kind of oh
that interaction oh that was actually
really good i'm
i was so not prepared for that i swear i
didn't try to make that happen but
ah sometimes we just weave coasters in
and out of each other out of necessity
even it just
looks so cool uh but yeah it kind of
echoes that first part of the layout
over here when you go down the first
drop and then
small airtime hill and again that curve
another airtime hill
all things considered i know it's a very
short layout but i do think it's a fun
layout for a mine train and especially
with that interaction that it has with
the spinning coaster as well
on so many of the trains especially
because they both well run two trains
and they get to do a lot of stuff
together
it's really fun and i think that's what
makes this map extra fun as well
and of course the stand-up coaster has a
lot of interaction
too now especially now that everything
around it is finished
you know it flies past the different
flat rides and then around the twister
and i think that's just a better day for
everybody
in all of these different rides so yeah
all together
i'm pretty happy with how yucatan ridge
turned out
it's not even quite as difficult of a
scenario as i thought but it still gave
a good challenge especially in terms of
the terrain i think
um it was quite tough to fit all of this
stuff in the map
but then again having to do so gives you
these opportunities to have really cool
interaction between different kinds of
rides
so i'm happy with it and i'm very ready
to move on to the next scenario which
to be honest i've completely forgotten
which one that is
so i guess we'll see in a second
now of course we got the the temple
piece as
the trophy here and i guess we just
moved to the next flying island then
yeah there we go
so this one's gonna be oh my god the
animation
ah right i know which one this is this
is to be brimstone peak
it's going to be an interesting episode
next time but yeah that's for the next
video
so thanks for watching guys and
i'll see you in the next one bye-bye